bonjour à tous sont s'intéresse aux
langues autochtones aujourd'hui vous
savez que 2019 et l année internationale
des langues autochtones décrétée par
l'onu
et l'année se termine alors on avait
commencé l'année avec une émission sur
les langues autochtones et lahonce et 10
décembre
il faut y revenir on y revient avec
isabelle picard bonjour isabel coixet
marie isabelle wendat de wayne d'accueil
on ne va pas évidemment faire la langue
en wendat l'émission wendat ça serait
bien intéressant mais c'est compliqué
exactement
également parmi nos invités aujourd'hui
anna mapachee qui est de pikogan donc
une anishnabe de pikogan bonjour oui
comment on dit ça va bien on anishnabe h
un détachement et beaucoup et c'est
commencé comme plus c'est c'est plus
tout le monde comprenne le mot mais est
ce que j'ai fait il ya un mot bonjour
spécifique en à michelet bon c'est quoi
c'est quoi même quand on dit beau matin
c'est quoi aussi comme par exemple on
dit bon matin a dit koe a été réveillé
c'est comme un accueil plus chaleureux
ah oui de dix jours ma tête oui alors
merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui pour
parler d'eux dans ce cas là on va parler
avec vous beaucoup d'avant gagny chanabé
merci d'être là et puis ellis queen
bonjour et licha oui bonjour alors
hellich journaliste donc au regard sur
l'arctique sur deux c'est un site sur
radio canada international donc l'année
internationale des langues autochtones
se termine déjà qu'est ce qu'on en
retient qu'est ce qu'il en reste
et surtout quelles sont les perspectives
d'avenir parce que oui il ya une année
internationale n'en veux pas que ça
s'arrête là on veut que ça pour ça se
poursuive isabelle ben oui on veut que
ça se poursuit bien sûr il ya quand même
eu dix initiatives intéressantes cette
année la part notamment du gouvernement
fédéral
oui qui a quand même adoptée en juin
dernier la loi sur les langues
autochtones et qui a mis un budget sans
la table de 334 millions de dollars en
lien avec ce donc ça c'est vraiment une
première
on ne pouvait bien sûr les retombées
tout de suite le dans l'est dans les
communautés étant donné bon qu'il était
les élections et ses erreurs mais on
espère beaucoup de cette nouvelle loi
leur gouvernement fédéral en tout cas il
ya quelque chose de nouveau c'est à
kiruna c'est le cours que vous donnez un
acquis grâce à ses nouveaux acquis yu-na
et les courants anishnabe oui c'est une
première en septembre c'est la première
que des corniches nab et j'ai aussi
l'année l'année dernière au sujet j'ai
commencé avec des mouchoirs pour ceux
qui n'ont rien noté nyan win
et vous êtes la seule preuve d'
anishnabe ici en région sûrement oui oui
oui donc avant que vous ne donniez le
court ça n'existait pas il y en avait
pas il y en avait une année au nos
communautés c'est ce qui a nourri les
dents l'extérieur de la communauté non
je sens qu'il est souvent à la recherche
d'un de professeurs n'avaient pas vrai
qu'il était temps que vous aviez mais à
pikogan par exemple dans l'est à l'école
primaire les enfants apprennent
anishnabe en bas âge moyen de maternelle
à la 6e année aussi au secondaire d'un
but qui a pas d'école secondaire la plus
courante
il ya l'école secondaire de secondes
grade 1 et 2
c'est là qu'il ya des cours aussi à
l'angle annabelle pour les fours
seulement des ce niveau secondaire et
dure seulement pour secondes et 2 après
sa 3 4 5 1 du quimpérois polyvalent dire
plus comme c'était la maison que ça se
passe alors hamrén normalement oui
est-ce que la niche nabé est une langue
encore très vivante sk beaucoup de gens
qui la peint c'est ce qui a beaucoup de
gens qui la parlent encore surtout en
haut de 45 ans dans ma communauté n'en
ont 45 ans la plupart parlent très bien
la langue comprends très bien les jeunes
les jeunes c'est un petit peu moins
longtemps traîne
c'est comme si elle est en train de
revivre ao non on travaille sociaux
ouais sur les que tout le monde puisse
avoir bénéficié de la langue trou puis
[Musique]
pikogan b sont en train de faire vivre
la langue dans le fond mais on l'a
jamais vraiment perdu on n'a pas perdu
c'est juste qu'on sait comme été un
temps mort oui maintenant c'est en train
de faire de la développer au niveau de
l'enseignement comment l'enseigner
l'agra m
oui on est en train de développer sont
aussi wii et le jeu justement dh et les
jeunesses est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est comme il comprend
la langue toujours mais c'est juste
c'est cesser de parler ou de communiquer
où ça devient difficile de donner un
exemple comme les enfants moi ma [ __ ]
ma plus vieille elle parlait aucun mon
français jusqu'à maternelle c'est comme
l'annoncé comme une des idées des rares
qui ont vraiment garder la langue
aujourd'hui kambale avant par l'afp je
lui parle en année chez novell mais
avant de répondre enfin 6 mhz
parce que en français c'est glauque au
oui d'accord
celles ci sont tous les chiffres oui
maintenant de la structure de la langue
comment elle est construite la langue
anishnabe comment elle fonctionne
comment un fonctionne c'est souvent se
serait imaginé que ce soit n'importe
quel mot il ya toujours un image
derrière c'est comme la traduction quand
tu traduis deux des dix nouveaux mauvais
que la pj est avancé et africains
essaient de trouver des mots mais il
faut toujours mettre une image derrière
de ce que ça veut dire telle ou telle
chose
ok alors prenons un exemple par exemple
maison comme on dit mais on aiguise one
thing i want you want qui veut dire best
maison je sais pas comment je pourrais
dire je crois peut-être donner un
exemple me guillaume promis guillaume
exemple même été bougies ouais mais
théologie qui veut dire l'âme de la
partie et ouais ouais ouais qui faisait
qu'y qui veut dire j'étais web et qui
veulent jeter mettez qui veut dire une
arme puis au gie qui veut dire qu'il
désigne la personne c'est ouais mais tu
es goji donc ce noble art c'est selon
qui jette les armes
un qui sait tout ces images là que tu
fais on devrait faire dans le fond oui
parce que souvent ça rit aussi dans
chaque communauté différentes aussi la
langue ils vont le franciser par exemple
je sais pas moi un taxi oui on voit les
critiques si par exemple on va l'écrire
à notre lacune dans la langue en
national mais aussi sur les communauté
anishinabe qui existe au québec
ben c'est cela sinon qu'on a vraiment
garder la langue mais les premiers
missionnaires qu'elle nous a montré a
été l écriture n'en ai fait que ces
autres qui ont nous on a vraiment garder
la l'alphabet de ce qu'on nous a montré
des premiers missionnaires et four quand
on compare les différentes langues
autochtones la niche nabi ça ressemble à
quelle autre langue autochtone et très
rapprochés à l'autre joueur bodji ouais
si tu connais parfaitement talent
heurter au niveau de la grande famille
avant vienne je parle des cris des
abénakis peut-être pas de zebina qui m
tous ceux qui comme l'écrivît zinou les
attikameks les autres j brel les années
chaîne abc vraiment si tu connais
parfaitement incapable de comprendre des
langues
puis je parle cru deux langues
différentes comme moi je parle je
comprends le cri aussi donc je capable
longuement les inouk y parle parce que
c'est comme un mélange les algonquins
écrit la langue à kiruna il ya combien
d'étudiants inscrits à votre cour je
n'ai pas beaucoup la ce moment parce que
c'était je sais que c'est un une
étudiante qui avait demandé le coup au
fait que j'en avais trop
c'est un bon début quand même ça
commence à l'écart à puis éventuellement
fait là je fais le niveau de la session
hiver pour je continue avec les mêmes
étudiants
oui est ce que c'est un coût qui
s'inscrit à l'intérieur d'un programme
ou un bowie l'intérieur d'un programme
je peux trouver exactement comment nexon
comme juste autonome s'ils veulent venir
apprendre la langue
alors je lance orton de moncaut aussi
fait que c'est ce qui n'a jamais
vraiment entendu les mouiller tout ça
mais
il ya principes et les deux autochtones
sont des anis nab et oui ce sont des
machines à bulles de deux center fait
que l'autre de lac simon
donc c'est des gens que c'est pas les
mêmes façons de dire dans chaque cas
volonté différente comme je l'avais qui
sont souvent c'est les mots sont
raccourcis ça dépend de beauce qui vient
fait qu'avec celles qui viennent de
senneterre et communique avec sa
grand-mère pea parle du ont commencé à s
comme universelles l'aider à connaître
le pratiquer avec sa main et à montréal
autochtone est ce que vous avez beaucoup
d'étudiants non je n'avais failli dans
la française la session l'année passée
aussi je vais commencer années de mon
choix puis j'en avais une dizaine 1%
cette année j'en avais 16 il ya de
l'espoir on voit qu'il ya de l'intérêt
il met thériault est ce que c'est vous
qui c'est moi qui ai créé tout c'est moi
qui explique le moteur par exemple jeu
pour les mois de l'année donc saviez
pourquoi qu'on le dit comme ça il ya
toujours une image derrière pourquoi ça
dépend toujours à la saison la saison ça
reflète la saison dans le fond oui
maintenant on a six saisons en a pas 4
sur wii comme les attikameks d'ailleurs
au 16 rue c'est beaucoup semblables oui
aux autres parce qu'ils ont eu un petit
peu différent l'oreille est un peu
différent mais j'ai quand même je
comprends quand même aucun cas une pas
surtout quand il écrit aussi je le
comprends alors là on est au mois de
décembre
comment ça se dit c'est comment on
appelle ce mois-ci cette série bones je
voudrais aussi
c'est la saison 2 le prix vers le privé
ni de libourne ne descend alors la niche
nabi fait partie des 6000 langues
autochtones qui sont parlées à travers
le monde
6000 langues mais combien sont encore
vivante vibrante qui en a de moins en
moins ouais c'est vrai on a de moins en
moins au canada y en a entre eux 70 et
90 des langues autochtones
dépendamment sur la classe qu'une longue
que le dialecte ou comme non donc c'est
ça qui va faire la différence
on en retrouve vraiment dans toutes les
provinces bien sûr dans tous les
territoires également le deux tiers de
ces l'angle au pays sont considérés
comme étant menacée quand même il reste
comme étant vulnérables donc vraiment il
faut faire un effort de rattrapage puis
ça presse
oui les trois langues les plus parlées
au canada c'est le cri lino petit lot et
la langue et nous mais il ya plein de
langues six ans hyper vivante comme chez
les attikameks 95% de la population dont
parlait la langue en inclut pas
là-dedans l'ouest parce que et c'est
fait au nombre de locuteurs qui sont pas
beaucoup mais si on regarde au niveau du
pourcentage prorata le vraiment ils sont
dans le haut selon qui est extrêmement
vive
oui absolument et là le wendat et la
niche nabi ne fait pas partie de ces
langues très parlé non il ya plusieurs
langues sont en voie d'extinction au
pays
hildahl abénakis le wendat était une
langue qui était complètement éteinte
exact depuis 1920 environ tout ce qu'on
avait c'était des vieux selene de cire
de l'ethnologue marius barbeau qui avait
fait dès qu'ils avaient enregistré des
chansons de personnes de chez nous des
gens âgés oui mais c'est tout ce qui
nous reste est à l'écouté
heureusement on avait beaucoup d'écrits
parce que les wendat ont été les
premiers à être touchés par les jésuites
en mêlée il ya eu des lexiques des
dictionnaires qui ont été écrits donc on
n'avait pas ça et on est une langue
cousine de la langue d'oc qui est
toujours parlé dans l'histoire c'est
intéressant et en 2006 si je me trompe
pas on est allé cogner à la porte de
l'université laval pour essayer de faire
un projet une alliance entre
l'université et notre communauté pour en
bout de ligne au bout de cinq ans
normaliser tout ça et faire revivre
et ça c'est fait on est allé chercher le
montant parce que ça coûte extrêmement
cher font embaucher des linguistes il
faut l'enseigner aussi cette langue là
qu'on voit qu'on veut normaliser à des
futurs enseignants qui eux vont
enseigner faut créer du matériel
pédagogique faut faire la recherche
manger terrain donc c'est un milliard $
qu'on est allé chercher à l'époque et
est donc c'est ce qu'on a fait et
maintenant la langue ou en date elle est
enseignée donc à l'école primaire à
l'école ouattara wendat qu'est lé
enseigne aussi à l'école aux adultes
on dit que c'est plus de 500 membres de
la communauté qui ont eu un jour ou
l'autre un cours d'introduction dans les
dernières années de la langue wendat
donc ça c'est extrêmement intéressant
pour certains c'est leur troisième
langue
on n'est pas encore rendu à pouvoir
converser en wendat dont quelques heures
sont capables d'avoir une conversation
du taux de base et les mots de base mais
quand même c'est vraiment une fierté
parce que c'était une longue qui était
complètement éteinte
il ya un énorme travail puis on continue
le travail est-ce que vos grands parents
vous parlez au rwanda est-ce que vous
l'aviez entendu jamais jamais comme
micro parents de toute manière
et tellement avant ma naissance donc
mais même là j'ai parlé avec mon père
qui me dit que même lui n'a jamais
entendu la langue parce que 1920 il aux
hébrides
on parle plutôt de la fin du 19e siècle
pour dire que c'était parler de manière
plus courantes
donc personne qui vit maintenant lille
homme entendu comme tel accord sur les
scènes de sirop et oui oui alors il ya
cette initiative là pour les wendat mais
y en a d'autres oui on a d'autres des
initiatives un peu partout au canada
en fait parce que pendant longtemps on
n'avait pas de budget pour le dossier de
la langue et de la culture ça a été le
problème est moins là il ya eu quoi 334
points en 4 millions bon on verra mais
pendant longtemps fallait se débrouiller
avec les moyens du bord et celle que de
le dire au début des années 2000 je
travaillais en culture chez moi et on
avait deux dollars 50 par personne par
individu pour la langue donc on et 2000
donc ça faisait cinq mille dollars pour
toute l'année donc pour des activités de
là on peut pas faire grand chose avec ça
donc il faut être extrêmement créatif
dans les communautés et souvent la
langue c'est pas une priorité non plus
du conseil de bande parce qu'il ya
tellement de besoins en logements non
potable en éducation en santé que la
langue bien que c'est important vous
reste donc si souvent du bénévolat c'est
s'aider des grands mères des coups comme
qui vont venir qui vont enseigner sur
l'heure du midi dans les écoles bâties
terrain donc de grâce aux pipots l'an
les gens de la base qui m'ont créé des
projets you quand même au niveau des
écoles des trucs intéressants on ne
parlait tout à l'heure que dans
certaines écoles ils vont enseigner
quelques heures par semaine leur langue
maternelle
maintenant il ya des écoles d'immersion
et ça c'est encore plus intéressant
entre autres chez les mots rock à cannes
et s'attaquer l'école je veux le dire
comme il faut rodez wang et et c'est une
école qui enseigne seulement les
programmes scolaires en lambeaux et donc
de la maternelle jusqu'à la sixième en
jusqu'à la sixième ils ont surtout
traduit ils ont traduit les livres de
mathématiques les livres d'histoire les
villes de gym la fibre bien sûr pas le
français il est quand même duré de
français mais oui il va se faire en un
mot appelé les professeurs ce sont des
locuteurs moat donc ça c'est une énorme
tâche
et ça c'est fait suite à la crise d'oka
redon
sur le terrain évidemment de la crise
d'oka ça a été une des retombées les
gens ont dit on veut faire revivre notre
langue notre culture c'est important et
donc soit y en a quelques-unes des
écoles comme ceux aussi à travers le
québec et le pays
et sinon on va enseigner quelques
périodes par semaine donc dans les
écoles il ya certaines écoles où ça va
se faire sur l'heure du dîner ou en
parascolaire
donc ça dépend mais souvent ce qu'on dit
c'est que ce n'est pas assez parce que
bien sûr les écoles autochtones doivent
suivre le cursus scolaire du québec du
ministère de l'éducation
et puis des fois c'est difficile de
trouver de la place à l'intérieur de se
mouvoir un bon eh oui oui oui
chez les amish nabé est-ce que c'est
suffisant ce qu'on enseigne actuellement
moi je trouve que non c'est pas assez
suffisant d'après moi non parce que j ai
toujours histoire aussi de la culture
derrière la langue aussi donc de faire
des activités culturelles tout ça c'est
très important parce que ça vient
vraiment de la langue la culture aussi
le fait que oui moi je gérais qu'il y
aurait plus de moutons des cas d'études
jeunes par exemple pour l'été allez
apprendre la langue la culture c'est
toutes les activités qu'il fallait
survient c'est ça ce serait un bon un
bon moyen pour pouvoir apprendre la
langue parce que quand on est à
l'extérieur de la communauté aussi
édifice est différent enfin quand de
l'excès de la communauté tape aurier qui
te dérange t d'emploi des activités
culturelles aussi c'est plus plaisant
c'est rassembleur tandis que dans la
communauté le monde le monde et moins
sont comme déranger un peu avec les
réseaux sociaux et tout seul comme mais
vous maintenant quand vous êtes arrivé à
l'université de montréal n'était pas
pour devenir enseignante d'aniche nabu
par la suite d'un non moi j'avais déjà
surtout que la médication oui le certain
que je vais continuer un bac mais
finalement au bout de deux sessions me
suis rendu compte que non
j'étais plus intéressé à aller enseigner
le français les mathématiques et ses
deux suites aux primaires mais j'ai
décidé je vous allez un petit enfance et
famille j'ai travaillé dans un esprit de
sorte qu'un passager y allions
inaugurait rome en données nominales en
études d'octobre jeter curieux je dis je
veux l'essayer
j'ai joué les deux avec j'ai fini les
deux en même temps
après ça j'ai vu que je veux de sertic
en éducation en 2004 que j'avais terminé
la loi 2007 je pensais d'avoir mon bac
par cumul finalement la loi et va
changer d'université de montréal donc
lyon le chef de mon certitude 2004 il
rentrait plus dans les dix ans donc
j'étais obligé de faire un nom sorti en
action communautaire fait que ça veut
vraiment voir des usa maintenant voir
comment faire pour niveau 2 et démons ma
communauté
mais le déclic d'enseigner la langue
c'est arrivé comment ben j'ai déjà
enseigné aussi à pikogan la langue jeu
d'enfant moi c'est vraiment
l'enseignement la langue et la culture
que - qui ne sait vraiment quand c'est
pour moi c'est important parce le en
étalant avoir une identité et voilà voir
la fierté et la culture passe par la
langue est inclus dans la culture c'est
indéniable l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
assesseur souvent ce que j'aime le moins
dans la danse qui arrive des fois c'est
que souvent on va essayer de de
franciser la langue par exemple on dit
bon matin un mois bon matin ça n'existe
pas comme ça chez nous on est en france
et non plus ça n'existe pas c'est jerry
sloan a glissé ce côté là je le disais
que c'est c'est pourquoi ces deux c'est
souvent ceux qui s'occupent de la langue
et souvent ils vont comme le franciser
mots par exemple moi sur moi comme pas
d'accord sur ça que j'aime toujours
aller chercher l'image de mon plus
l'image derrière fait pourquoi c'est
donner ce qu'on n'est pas alors comme
excuse non comme le mot ordinateur
wheeling
moment c'est ce que voulait dire ok
d'ordinateurs mes parents aux autres
qu'il disait notre en place également
magna gardait qui fait l'action de taper
sur un clavier
ok d'un fonds s'est séparé comme le
micro quand c'est arrivé à quoi ça sert
le micro mais ça sert à réchauffer fait
qui appelait ça joue sajou ce n'est pas
la presse l'agencé gamme c'est un objet
un sujet qui fait qu'il est chaud mais
comme on dit télévision canale 5
c'est une image qui donne derrière
l'écran qui donne l'image l'écran ce que
ça dit tu vois tu as toujours l'image de
ceux de ce que la chose va faire l'objet
va faire ou c'est comme souvent aussi on
m'a déjà posé la question comment on dit
intervention en appelant ses trouvailles
c'est trop gros on est vraiment s'il
faut vraiment sa soeur spécifique est le
roux contexte de ce que de quoi on va
parler par exemple combien de mots dans
la langue attikameks indiqué pardon dans
la langue à nice où l'abbé tu veux dire
comment que de l'alphabet à belle-île
l'alphabet ya combien de lettres
13h13 lettre mais il ya combien de mots
dans la langue hop il ya beaucoup de
monde je peux pas décrire combien cas
nous c'est vraiment beaucoup le se
connaît parfaitement talent est inconnu
plaît c'est le sait aussi l'enseignement
aussi quand l'enceinte si on prend comme
le français on se base sur le français
pour lancer nil comme les comment au
présent ou passé au futur on se bouge un
peu sur les conjugaisons divergent eu
raison de leur part oui comment bhl
comme qui a aussi dans une phrase dans
la nationale b c'est pas le sujet verbe
complément comme en français oui oui oui
que c'est comme à l'envers
oui je vois souvent et il va de la fin
mais ça peut être en avant aussi tout
dépendant de la force que vous construit
oui oui
elisha prendre nos petits tout vous
classez même dans les lycées
ça quand vous écoutez anna ce que vous
voyez des liens dans we will agences
tout le monde les mots oui oui c'est la
même chose et puis je sais pas si c'est
la même chose en nba mais on est une
petite route il ya toutes les fictions
fixé chaque un jour tu n'es léman où
elle nous enseigne racine alors c'est
possède le landais tellement riche et
pied mais comme vous avez dit il faut
que la culture soit derrière ça on est
toutes ses nuances et puis les
inflexions qu'on donne oui certains
projets pour la vie pour eux à l'europe
d'en parler hellich chez les familles
donc quand on se retrouve de l'autre
côté un du pôle nord d'autres de côté
vers là on ne parle pas l'arctique
je veux dire il ne parle pas une petite
ou oui c'est limite 8 août au sinon
c'est la langue ça me laisse avoué je
dirais les landes et lancer encore les
questions des langues et dialectes
oui c'est comme tellement intéressant de
voir les deux les enjeux qu'on qui
existe au canada pour comment préserver
la langue autochtone et les façons de
parler soit en éducation et le sait
justement j'allais le dire vous n'étiez
pas là la semaine passée quand on a
parlé de dévaloriser les du casier
voulais je regardais lyon gelé comme un
peu le sujet c'est quand même pas entre
les messieurs juste pour les gens qui
peut-être connu police a misé un peuple
autochtone qui leur territoire tous les
signaux s'appelle sap mi mai il était
par le frontier divisée comme nation la
russie la finlande la suède et la
norvège voilà mais il se considère comme
un peu divisé par 4 frontières et toutes
les problématiques
il est même chose des pensionnats
autochtones dans le pays nordique la
suppression de leur culture pendant des
centaines d'années alors la la la la
situation avec le langue c'est très
précaire unesco puisque toutes les
langues ou dialectes famille ce soit en
danger ou en danger critique
le langue avec les pays nordiques la
façon qu'ils ramassent les statistiques
c'est ça empêche des fois les gens de
demander les questions sur le site et
puis si on n'aide pas les données qui
perd scientifique mais les amis du nord
lelangue de samy de nos qui le plus
parler ya à peu près 25 mille personnes
qui le parlent ou c'est que beaucoup de
dépôts beaucoup et quand on voit les
autres disaient nous voulons c'est comme
de moins en moins avec les petites
familles comme 30 personnes qui en
parlent maintenant
mais leur approche maintenant c'est très
intéressant et c'est comme exactement
comme vous avez dit c'est la langue est
pas destinée de la culture est ce que
les autorités ça me vois dans les trois
pays norvège la suède et la finlande
c'est que la langue on avait des amis
qu'on essaie d'apprendre une langue mais
sans la culture vivante derrière et ça
veut dire que des fois même les enfants
ça me il comprend mais il parle plus
parce qu'ils sont trop inondé par les
cultures de pays nordiques oui mais
maintenant les autorités sami dans les
trois pays différents
la russie participé à cause de la
situation politique se met pas les amis
de la russie de participer
il veut aller à la base maintenant et
développer une pédagogie un creux qu'ils
nomment pré scolaire pour les enfants
s'est mis dans tout le pays alors
développé sa est transférée ça ça aussi
on est un enfant famille pour en prendre
le pays en est que on va avoir c'est
pédagogique développé pour les cultures
et l'enfant sammi mais comme dit dans
les centres et les trois pays
oui c'est au hockey dans l'es3 puis dans
les écoles louis ses amis et c'est
tellement ambitieux et j'ai eu le
plaisir de rencontrer ces gens-là quand
j'étais en reportage cette année et a
dit qu'avec toutes les recherches que on
sait même pas une famille aujourd'hui un
enfant ça me c'est quoi le meilleur
façon de transmettre la culture parce
que la réalité ce que c'est plus grands
parents parents enfin ils ont dans les
systèmes d'une village et puis comme le
système d'éducation comme vous avez dit
c'est comme faut respecter
éducation dans les pays chauds comment
on peut incarner soeur et ceux où ils
ont reçu l'argent le gouvernement de
norvège 2 c'est entre cinq cent mille
six cent mille dollars
et c'est une projet pilote ils ont passé
le lien mis à deux années de devait le
pays
cette approche là et d'avoir la culture
soit les d'apprendre la langue à travers
les cultures et paraissait d'apprendre
la langue des racines et de la culture
et au geste amos
oui oui le projet samossa excusez moi je
peux dire le nom mais aussi il veut que
ce que les gens soient capables de
transférer cette pédagogie curriculum
peu importe la culture ses amis ou ses
le multi sami parce que les amis ils
sont connus pour tous les éleveurs de
rennes mais aussi des chasseurs et les
pêcheurs sur les amis qui vivent sur les
coupes nationales tic tout le
vocabulaire et la culture s'est basé sur
les mots pollution les poissons mais les
familles qui vivent dans nos forêts
c'est le différents lycées les concepts
pour la chasse le concept culturel et du
blanc seau il veut pas en manger ni à
manger ni zay la culture famille et on
est fous développer quelque chose qui on
peut transférer pour cissé une
communauté dans la forêt en fait langue
ou si une communauté sur le coteau de
sénèque tango voilà qu'à oui il seul
endroit le carton petit peu et il
commence avec le le préscolaire parce
qu'il dit avec toute la culture
dominante c'est tellement comme ils sont
les enfants soit inondé avec ça et si il
attend juste que l'écho première est
déjà trop tard
selon yves apprend seul en train de
choisir neuf écoles pour les projets
pilotes maintenant et pour les
prochaines trois années il va essayer
différentes choses mais il va toujours
changer fait les modifications pour qu'à
la fin de trois ans ils ont l'idée plus
fixe equal la meilleure façon
d'apprendre la culture et la langue
autochtone et l'espoir c'est après soeur
s'il peut montrer que ça marche que les
les ministères éducation nationale peut
être adoptée soeur comme une partie de
l'accord et qui n'est officiel pour les
enfants s'amusent c'est très ambitieux
et aussi c'est très ambitieuse et très
ambitieux mais ces gens là c'est comme
quand j'étais en suède il ya tout les
représentants de la défend pied qui
étaient là et c'est vraiment là ils
attaquent à ça et puis parce qu'il dit
ça marche pas ici on n'avait pas changé
par les choses avaient d'autres auteurs
comme les langues sont en danger
oui c'est ça mais l'autre élément qui
est très intéressant c'est que il vaut
aussi que cette pédagogie c'est le coeur
qui l'homme va pas être comme isolé dans
ce qui mine était sami il dit des amis
parce que un peu comme au canada il ya
de plus en plus des gens qui vit au
milieu urbain et adele et ses amis nos
enfances amis devraient avoir les doigts
avec le les doigts internationale pour
les droits des autochtones ont il veut
que même des enfants familles qui sont à
oslo ou helsinki que aussi il a accès à
ce que réclament aussi et ils essaient
de partir ça pour que 1 enseignante même
si l'ancien enseignante et peuvent pas
couramment les amis que le croquis nommé
tellement forte que même des milieux
open
les amis un doigt de l'éducation dans le
temps mais tout leur poids pour jouer la
victoire
c'est ambitieux comme projet est
ambitieux et ça beaucoup de cesser ces
questions ici dans l'article indienne
avec les inuits ça fait longtemps qu'ils
discutent
est-ce qu'on devrait essayer de faire
les livres pour les enfants ensemble
pour empêcher d'avoir comme un livre en
ont le dialecte labrador ou au piano etc
comme c'est très très complexe mais
c'est intéressant de voir de suivre ces
projets l'heure pour voir ce que les
aliments qui serait intéressant pour les
canadiens sur c est très intéressant me
ronger absolument est ce que la langue
des samis pourrait devenir un jour la
langue officielle de ces pays là une des
langues officielles évidemment avec les
autres langues parlées question ben
question lieu que c'est difficile de
parler de ça au général
que les réalités dans l'es3 puis son
centre est effarant oui mais malgré tout
ça il manque lui le danger de les
langues et dialectes il comme des
réussites et cette année je sais pas si
vous avez vu ça le film frozen 2 il va
sortir sa effet le fruit d'une
collaboration entre bordini piles etc 3
parlement ses amis dans les pays
nordiques et savez tous dans nos langues
de samy du nord qui on a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est le plus parler mais il dit
plus haut c'est la langue des
autochtones les langues internationaux
pour cette année et dit c'est comme
d'avoir une réussite comme ça parce que
c'est vraiment il faut cibler les
enfants avant que il rien trop comme
pris dans l'allée du cassieu
signification de la culture dominante
pour me suis dit que mieux frosine ça
c'est une réussite qui réussit alors
c'est comme si intéressant là on voit
qu'il ya des choses qui se passent et
puis et aussi comme avec le film frozen
u10 a fait une énergie autour de la
langue et que le problème c'est que vous
avez été avec les enfants même si les
enfants comprend la langue
il ya comme une gêne de parler où il
faut vraiment franchir ses plaquages
pour faire avancer la langue
oui isabelle je me tourne vers vous pour
la même question les langues autochtones
au canada devrait tel est ce possible
qu'elle devienne un jour des langues
officielles un peu parce que
l'expérience s'est fait ailleurs en
nouvelle zélande
oui avec laminé maori langues
officielles ouais mais au canada et en
fait c'est qu'il ya énormément de
l'angola dit tout à l'heure en 69,92 ne
pourrez pas choisir que nous deux ou
trois ça fonctionne pas comme il
faudrait tout les reconnaître et puis le
statut des langues officielles ben si ça
fait partie la constitution canadienne
donc pour faire ça faudrait rouvrir la
constitution canadienne
la posture que le gouvernement fédéral
est prêt à faire cela c'est ça veut dire
plein de choses mais ce serait
absolument extraordinaire
nonobstant ces eaux car même maintenant
à la chambre des communes à ottawa les
députés qui ont le droit depuis l'an
passé si je me trompe pas de s'exprimer
dans
leur langue autochtone et il ya des
traducteurs qui sont des interprètes
donc pour pouvoir traduire en anglais ou
en français donc ça c'est quand même
vraiment intéressant donc ses impôts je
pense vers une reconnaissance
il ya aussi marc milieu que je veux pas
passer sous silence qui est maintenant
un ministre d etat aux histoires
autochtones wii et qui lui il y aura un
autochtone
non bien sûr et qui est député ici à
montréal et qui a appris la langue en
anglais la langue du rock
oui un peu en cachette pendant plusieurs
années et tout d'un coup il est arrivé à
la chambre des communes il ya fait un
discours en langue ganger moi le fait
plusieurs même par la cie c'est vrai de
plus en plus long et ça ça a
certainement influencé je pense le reste
des députés l'offre dans tout ce qui est
la loi qui a été déposé chez terra mais
je sache aussi s'exprimer en crise son
parlement canadien oui positif soit
vraiment ça démontre que les langues
sont encore vivants gaz ont leur place
et que ça fait partie de toute la
décolonisation
oui oui absolument est ce qu'on a déjà
entendu la langue anishnabe résonner au
parlement canadien
je prends ma connaissance non c'est sûr
que dans abitibi c'est un peu comme
quand même une région isolée fake c'est
moins tu arrives dans amos par exemple
dans un hôtel c'est écrit en inde et
chine avaient bienvenus oui c'était
aussi oui c'est sûr que les crises sont
beaucoup plus avancés au niveau de la
langue même si non je pense dernièrement
il ya eu une loi sur ce qui doit l
doivent parler la langue des cris quand
tu travailles pour mai sont très
avancées décrite par rapport à la langue
d'après moi parce que c'est quand même
sont quand même plus que les communautés
autochtones sont en région isolée plus
qu'il la sauvegarde là où il n'existe
qu'ici bas chez les années chez nab est
un peu ce seront je sais pas comment je
pourrais dire mais je peux pas vraiment
d le tout pourcentage qu'il n'est pas
des gens parlent mais
chez nous c'est beaucoup de monde qui la
parle quand même et si c'est comme je
disais l'élite par exemple les échos
jeudi
une phrase sur un chiffre je vois dit le
chef en france et au lieu de le dire le
chiffre en français c'est vraiment long
oui c'est long à dire
donc c'est pour raccourcir les on se
simplifient r c'est toujours une bonne
chose mais souvent je pense que si je
les ai donc su c'est comme ce oui oui
c'est quand même chez les moi aussi moi
j'ai vécu longtemps et qui est attaqué
puis à l'espace de trois générations
envoyait malheureusement la langue
disparaît donc j'avais ma belle-mère qui
aujourd'hui aurait peut-être 80 ans qui
avait le mot comme langue maternelle et
qui parlait toujours avec mon beau-père
langue gunning et les enfants comprenez
mais parlait à peine des petits mots des
petites phrases et les petits enfants
c'était zéro c'est en l'espace de deux
j'ai deux ou trois générations vraiment
donc il faut vraiment secoué le truc
pour pour pouvoir sauvegarder pu
transmettre les langues c'est bordeaux
oui oui oui la loi sur les langues
autochtones qui a finalement et qui est
passée là cet été au parlement canadien
ça va changer quoi
mais ça a été fait en tout cas c'était
en juillet bonjour oui je servirai la
fac ne sait absolument mais ça a été
cette fois l'heure elle a été rédigé en
collaboration avec des organisations
inuits métis et des premières nations
donc déjà là il y à une collaboration
importante au niveau des organisations
autochtones on du pays donc j'imagine
que pour la suite des choses puisqu'il
était déjà je vous interromps il fait on
va regarder parce que ça c'est la carte
qui montre les langues autochtones
partout à travers
on les voit tout et donc comme les
organisations autochtones était déjà
impliqué au niveau de la loi dans wii de
l'élaboration de la loi je pense
qu'elles vont l'être aussi au niveau du
plan d'action pour tout ce qui va suivre
mais on attend de savoir on est dans un
bon point d'interrogation comme
plusieurs dossiers évidemment on vient
de rentrer en charnière si je me trompe
exact voilà avec le discours du trône
qui va les présenter hier pour terminer
je vais vous invité et je vais inviter
sur tous les gens qui nous écoutent
assister à un spectacle a lieu la
semaine prochaine les 11 et 12 décembre
et là vous allez m'aider à la parce
qu'en fait le spectacle
il est d'une autre anishnabe c'est
emilie monnaie emilie en fait ses
origines c'est bretonne comme moi et
anishnabe de kitigan zibi est en fait
elle présente un spectacle à montréal ça
s'appelle alors là le terme c'est qu'ici
way qui si oui ok jiwa qui veut dire
ceux qui parlent fort ceux qui parlent
fin ceux qui parlent pas voilà elle
présente donc lexique de 13 mois
autochtone qui donne un sens alors ça va
être intéressant d'aller se muscler
leurs oreilles avec les langues
autochtones ça se passe à montréal les
12 à 11 et 12 décembre aller fouiller là
dessus pour en savoir plus il ya
beaucoup d'artistes qui en font partie
en fait de ce spectacle 13 langues très
artiste est entre autres marie andrée
guilde tomson highway
il va y avoir exergue également
alexandre nekoi d'eau enfin plusieurs
personnes je pense avec une belle
découverte ici à montréal
voilà un dernier mot est ce que vous
avez un dernier mot parce que l'on va
bientôt quitter l'écran mais avez-vous
une dernière chose à dire sur les
langues autochtones
ben je pense que je content de voir que
dans plusieurs communautés les lans
seulement les les gens de la base donc
de grâce aux pipots oui c'est vrai mais
les conseils de bande ou s'ils sont en
train de se réveiller à l'importance de
la sauvegarde de la langue parce qu'on
le disait c'est la langue c'est la
culture c'est le territoire tout sauvian
sera vraiment une idée belle initiative
dont je pense qu'il était temps que ça
se passe voilà ah non je suis d'accord
avec toi moi aussi je trouve que
depuis que moi je suis ici arrivée à
montréal c'est vraiment la langue de
chine à berne drake est remonté de rien
plus vivantes ici c'est sûr que
j'aimerais bien le faire dans ma
communauté tout ça mais j'ai des gens
qui sont là aussi avec 6 au niveau de la
langue pour moi c'est vraiment important
de la sauvegarder
fait ici un état à montréal c'est ce que
je parle pas beaucoup a pas beaucoup de
monde qui la parle ici je suis comme
vraiment seul je donne des cours est ce
que c'est ça puis ça aussi ça sale aide
les gens à voir que d'autres langues qui
a d'autres dans le fond si la
réconciliation autour de nous connaître
en tant qu'autochtones pour moi c'est
c'est important de transmettre la langue
la culture et puis a brisé un peu les
stéréotypes et tout seul mais lâchez pas
en tout cas vous en avez beaucoup sur
les épaules puisque c'est vous qui l'ont
fait ici à montréal
merci beaucoup merci à ma platine
d'avoir participé à cette émission
je vous laisse répéter merci en national
me wade voilà merci encore une fois
isabelle participer à cette émission et
hills queens merci beaucoup merci alors
en innu petit tout ça vaut la peine de
les entendre les organismes beauty is it
en innu petit tout on dit comment merci
tout indique selon la région dans lequel
raconte
merci à toutes les trois et merci à vous
d'avoir été là encore une fois cette
semaine à l'ecoute la semaine prochaine
nous allons faire le bilan d'un an de
pouvoir de la caq à québec et nous
allons voir ce qui a été fait pour les
autochtones au québec au cours de la
dernière année nous recevrons entre
autres ghislain picard merci à vous à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]